we're supposed to take seriously the
notion that somehow they aren't able to
determine who brought cocaine into the
White House like like they don't have
security cameras everywhere like there
isn't constant surveillance if you if
you pick your nose driving down the
highway you can be certain that your
dirty deed was documented by 47
different cameras yet if you bring a
controlled substance into the White
House and leave it there okay so you you
take it out of your pocket or wherever
you're stashing it God knows where and
leave it there somehow it's not caught
by any cameras at all I mean they have a
log of every single person who enters
that building when they enter where they
go when they leave and somehow it's just
it's not possible